[Music]
[Music]
this is Branford's motorsports race I'm
sponsored by Playstation
hello guys welcome to Gran Turismo sport
race on three years ago I was playing
PlayStation same spot as you I was
racing against other people and I'm glad
to raise real race cars all around the
world now it's your turn to go
head-to-head this challenge you guys
start racing each other it's fun house
against GameSpot the overall winner
unanimous against me hopefully you don't
beat me otherwise I'll have to do
something else for living what advice
would you have since we're about to take
our first step into that bigger world
I think the brake pedal you can brake
way way later and way way higher than a
normal Road car now the simulators are
really accurate when you are on straight
line you have to keep the pedal really
really hard and then go off really quick
because you lose downforce so it's
hitting that perfect window with braking
and a perfect window turning and a
perfect acceleration to get to the loop
that's part of the nuance of it yeah for
me online racing is the best training
for a real race driver because it's the
same perfect atmosphere to Train ok guys
this is it race on we're gonna do some
rock paper scissors to see who is going
to go against whom so let's start with
the fun house I've been practicing
have you been a parachute ready what do
you do
yep 1 2 3 I was practicing
all right here we go who's gonna rip us
luck 1 2 3 shoot
gotcha all right I'll try to defend the
team all right
Sonique against Loras good luck guys
like Nick good luck
promise there will bump you too many
times only a few look good as our
beautiful cards
a little confident oh you already
probably passed it
oh wow there's that thing yeah just
going out for groceries you know it is
gotta give you a little bit of
confidence let you get out yeah yeah
give me give me give me a lot of room so
I can I can mess up I just messed up I
just messed up oh no I should be hanging
back here waiting for your time to
strike
I see how it is yeah okay easy now I
took the wall I did it let's go here we
go hey hey it's getting spicy now you're
like a horse race I'm waiting to make my
move four seconds to move you remember
how many laps they're hard cuz I don't
sorry you just gotta go fast gotta go
fast all the time
laughs don't mean anything fast it's
everything oh don't hit that wall and I
tapped it live left soooo uh just a
little is he catching up back there come
on baby make it smooth
ol Leadfoot over here what a move
[Music]
nice spice clean cos or he overshoot the
car then he comes Laura's now then you
know I was weird that was weird
all that work to let you come right back
in it's gotta be sporting it's a name in
a game quite literally
oh boy just made any slip-up that's
gonna cost that's gonna go site right
side off the inside eight touch they
touch they touch putting me over here
like this that's not that's not here we
go this is it for all tomorrow this is
the final all right
I just gotta push it Yolo
I'm sweating and it's not because it's
hot in this room western
Oh Arawa Oh oh my god oh wow less than a
half a second separating us that was
regardless of losing that was a great
race my arms are still shaking and I'm
not holding the controller yeah they're
a flash steering wheel there medic
around this is a seat pop out and you
just carry me out on this thing oh yeah
oh I don't feel like I'm 20 years older
now hold on what about the race Congrats
man thank you thanks race sorry Nick
you know how we lose sometimes we learn
now I mean you guys did an amazing job
the race was really clean and advice for
unique is about you about your race line
I think you can use the whole track
sometimes it's better to go wide on the
beginning you click the apex you go down
and then you go up again so you can roll
more speed in and go more speed out you
will use less student input and this
will make you faster and Lawrence
I like the race line I think the race
line look really really proud so
sometimes you were really a bit under
the limit you can push more the car and
don't use the brake so you can leave the
throttle earlier and keep more momentum
through the corner and hopefully
Lawrence you can win the next one and
see you maybe at the end another one
I'll go do some push-ups one but for the
next race
[Applause]
[Music]